tras semanas de agitación dentro de su
coalición de gobierno el primer ministro
italiano giuseppe conte presentó su
renuncia este martes al presidente
sergio matar el a el máximo árbitro de
las crisis políticas
el presidente del arte y presidente de
la república se reserva el derecho a
decidir qué hacer a continuación e
invitó al gobierno a permanecer en el
cargo en calidad de interino
la semana pasada conte perdió la mayoría
absoluta en la cámara alta del senado lo
que no le dejó otra opción que provocar
una crisis formal de gobierno y así
ganar tiempo para encontrar un acuerdo
con los otros partidos mataré la abrirá
entonces una ronda de consultas este
miércoles para analizar las diferentes
salidas a la crisis pero la intención de
contes que el presidente le vuelva a
encargar otro mandato para comprobar
posibles nuevas mayorías hasta ahora los
principales partidos de la coalición el
movimiento 5 estrellas y el partido
democrático han respaldado sus esfuerzos
para mantenerse en el poder
el país está pasando por uno de los
peores momentos de su historia a causa
de la pandemia y se encuentra en una
absurda crisis de gobierno por el
egoísmo de unos ahora necesitamos unidad
debemos unirnos todos a giuseppe con
'the pero si el intento de formar un
nuevo gobierno fallan el presidente
tendrá que convocar a elecciones dos
años antes de lo previsto aunque los
analistas políticos dicen que este es el
escenario menos probable